now Donald Trump is about to make
history by becoming the first former U.S
president to face criminal charges he's
expected to leave his New York residence
shortly for the court building and
office of Manhattan's district attorney
the charges are unclear but are linked
to hush Money Paid to a porn star who
claims she had an affair with Trump he
says the case is politically motivated
and is calling on supporters to protest
Kristen salumi joins us now outside the
courthouse in New York she joins us on
the phone so first of all tell us what
we expect to unfold in court today
Kristen
um I hear that you guys are having
problems with the desert signal
10 minutes or so we've seen police
presence ramp up outside the courthouse
the street has been closed to traffic
more barricades have been put up police
are being very deliberate in redirecting
pedestrians away from the courthouse at
this time not allowing people to stop
and take pictures even though we're
seeing a tremendous amount of public
interest in what's happening at the
courthouse where I'm standing outside
people coming by coming out of their
offices to try to snap a picture and as
well as demonstrators some of whom have
come from other parts of the country to
show their support for president Trump
also detractors of President Trump we're
seeing around here as well but in terms
of what we expect when the president
gets here clearly the massive amounts of
news crews who are on the scene are
hoping to get a glimpse of the president
we don't know if that will be possible
outside due to the security measures
once he's inside he will be be processed
have this fingerprints taken he will do
some paperwork and then be escorted into
a courtroom we may get a glimpse of him
on video in that hallway as he makes his
way to the courtroom but the judge is
not allowing any cameras in the court to
witness the proceeding but reporters who
waited all night to get in the courtroom
will be allowed in to see the
proceedings at that time the president
will be formally charged we expect or
hope to hear the specific charges that
will be leveled against him at that time
or shortly thereafter we expect the
president to enter and not guilty plea
of course these charges are all related
to the hush money payment that was made
on his behalf in the run-up to the 2016
election
but the specifics of the charges have
yet to be revealed so the whole
proceeding once president Trump is
inside probably will only take an hour
or two
but a lot of anticipation this is just
the first step of a legal proceeding
for and the entire process can take
months if not a year but obviously a lot
of focus a lot of attention on the first
time a former presidents being charged
in a courthouse and after the actual
proceeding takes place we expect
president Trump to go back to Florida
and we expect the prosecutor district
attorney Alvin Bragg who's overseeing
this case to speak to the media for the
first time since the charges against the
president were filed so we are all
waiting outside the course courthouse on
Tinder hooks just waiting for this
process to get underway
and Kristen you mentioned there this
could take months if not a year or more
and when a final ruling is in is is a
key question is it not because at the
same time this is not only unusual
because he's a former president he's
running again for the White House in any
result from this judicial process could
impact that race right
absolutely president Trump has already
declared that he will run again in 2024
and under U.S law even if he were
convicted of a crime he could still run
for president uh the president happened
to use this turn of events which would
of course be seemingly a negative uh
turn of events being charged for a crime
he's attempted to turn it to his favor
to use it to Rally his base he is
declaring it's a Witch Hunt that the
prosecutor is making these charges
against him in order to sway the 2024
election and he's called on his
supporters to rally on his behalf and
that apparently he's raised more than
four million dollars in the last week
since the charges came to life since the
news came to light that he was going to
be facing these criminal charges but of
course this isn't the the only uh
criminal case or the only investigation
facing president Trump and all of these
will play out over the next year and the
run-up to that election
so again you would think that would be a
negative thing that would hurt someone
running for office and certainly his
detractors who we've also seen out here
demonstrating
would think it should disqualify him
from running for president or being
president but for many of the supporters
they're saying this is just more
evidence that the cultural and
presidential Elite the political Elites
are against uh Trump so uh and bring it
for me yeah and so uh sorry a lot going
on here outside the courtroom but a lot
of excitement a lot of anticipation as
we wait to see the next steps play out
they need to go live all right Kristen
thanks for that let's go visit Gabriel
Elizondo he's also in Manhattan he's
been keeping an eye on protests how
they've been shaping up
yeah there are protesters both Pro and
anti-trump protesters they're closer to
where Kristen is on the front of the
courthouse just about a block and a half
from where I'm at everything I've been
there all morning and everything has
been pretty peaceful just a lot of
shouting back and forth the police are
keeping every all the protesters in one
park right across from the front
entrance of the courthouse and they're
dividing them with barricades uh
separating the two groups of protesters
so there aren't any problems where I'm
at now is on the back side of the
courthouse just to give you an idea uh
I'm on the opposite end of the Court
complex from where Kristen is at right
now why are we here because this is
where Trump will be brought in through
the back entrance of the courthouse you
can see some people here it's some
tourists some just residents the
sidewalk is open there's obviously some
journalists here but most of them are at
the front of the courthouse and this is
where once Trump leaves Trump Tower it's
about six kilometers drive to this
location and this is where we believe
his motorcade will come in and they will
shut down these streets completely and
he'll be brought in on this street
behind this police car
it's just one second it's just one
second behind this police car and then
uh that's where he'll be brought in to a
back entrance there
that's why we're here monitoring that
and uh as soon as he leaves Trump Tower
this is where he will get in he will not
probably not go in the front entrance
where uh there are hundreds if not
thousands of more journalists there so
pretty much every entrance to the court
is being staked out right now all right
and since you've been Gabriel you know
watching those protesters give us an
idea of how the the idea if not the
image which will emerge of Donald Trump
being charged being fingerprinted I know
there's been some question of whether
he's going to get mug shots or not
um how is that playing out in the psyche
of Americans thank you
yeah I mean when I talked to the Trump
supporters I asked them why are you here
and they say uh because they feel this
is political persecution those are what
the Trump supporters say almost echoing
exactly what Trump has been saying
himself over the last several days they
say they're here to support a former
president uh Trump but this is clearly
unprecedented situation I mean we've
said the word unprecedented so many
times over recent days but just can't be
said enough uh and there's a lot of
sense of almost shock and disbelief uh
by everyone here of what's actually
happening a former president indicted
showing up to surrender uh even with
anti-trump protesters
they were almost in shock as well and an
interesting thing is you talk to both
sides and both sides are holding up
signs
of people just to let viewers know
watching pictures of that Decay that we
understand that is Donald Trump he's
leaving his residence in New York and
heading over probably to where you're
located Gabrielle pretty soon so the
Heat's coming your way
yeah that's right it's like I said it's
about six kilometers let's walk around
just a little bit more it's about six
kilometers from where Trump Tower is to
right where we're at and you can already
see a little bit more of activity as
within a minute or two as soon as Trump
gets within about uh a kilometer or so
from here they're gonna definitely close
these streets completely to all traffic
they can do that at a moment's notice
here
and this is where we expect his
motorcade either to come in this
direction or the opposite direction
and be brought here it's going to happen
all very quickly the camera shot you're
seeing now is the actual entrance where
we believe the actual entrance where we
believe Trump uh will be brought into
and you won't be able to see him when he
gets out of his vehicle uh because
they're bringing him through a back
entrance and this is for security
reasons uh it's just unprecedented
security here getting a former president
to this location where again on the
other side of the courthouse you have
hundreds perhaps even now over a
thousand uh pro-trump protesters you
have several hundred anti-truck
protesters on the other side of the
courthouse you can see it's much calmer
here and that's probably why they plan
to bring Trump in in this direction and
you can already see actually they're
starting to close the streets as I'm
looking up the street here you see some
officers starting to walk down a little
bit starting to get in position
uh down the street here as they're
waiting for that motorcade to get here
again six kilometers uh he's got a
police escort of course you can now see
some ambulances and Sirens So within the
next few minutes I would say they'll
totally block this off in preparation
for uh Trump's motorcade of course
they're monitoring it the police are
obviously in communication with each
other as well as a secret service and
FBI I should say is involved in security
as well and as soon as he gets within a
few blocks they'll completely block this
off just for for safety reasons
let me just talk a little bit Gabriel do
stay with me but I want to talk a little
bit to these pictures and we just let
them breathe for a second to take in
the historic nature of this moment
okay that's a motorcade bringing a
former U.S president to a court in New
York where he will be arraigned arrested
and criminally charged
that has never happened before in the
history of the United States of America
to a sitting or former U.S president
we understand he's just a few kilometers
away from that process officially
beginning
Gabriel maybe we you can explain to us
we know of course what arrest and
arraignment might mean in the usual
context
what does it mean in terms of how Donald
Trump will be treated
will it be will there be handcuffs jail
cells mug shots fingerprinting
well under normal procedures anyone that
is indicted would be brought here and
they would be photographed and sometimes
handcuffs that's under normal procedures
but it's important to remember here that
while Donald Trump was indicted he has
not been convicted of any crime yet and
that's a big difference and so when this
process we're seeing play out right now
this historic process that we're seeing
on live television right now is it it's
part of the normal process of a a
someone that's been indicted
surrendering so
will he be handcuffed we are told no
that's what we have been told that is by
different sources that the secret
service does not want him handcuffed and
that there's really no need to handcuff
him we are told this is not from the
district attorney this is just what
we've been hearing from various sources
uh from various law enforcement agencies
when you handcuff someone you want to
detain them there's really no reason in
this situation to detain somebody as
high profile as an ex-president who's
turning himself in willingly that's
number one will there be a mug shot well
that's the photograph the short answer
to that is we quite frankly don't know
we've heard that there will be a mug
shot we've also heard that perhaps there
will not be a mug shot we might not know
until Donald Trump gets here gets inside
that court building and it might not be
till afterwards that we even know if he
had a mug shot so listen unprecedented I
can tell you what normally happens in
situations like this when someone is
indicted and they're brought here to
surrender but again this is not a normal
situation so while the district attorney
says that they are going to treat
everyone the same I can also tell you
that there are certain
safety security precautions that can be
negotiated here so the key is going to
be after Donald Trump is fingerprinted
and maybe photographed that process
could take as long as an hour he will be
brought to a courtroom within this
complex here and there will be cameras
we're told in the hallway for a short
walk where they'll be able to photograph
Donald Trump as he walks into the
courtroom so listen
it's it's unprecedented and there's some
things about the next hour to two hours
or so we simply might not know what
happens until afterwards
all right that's that's an important
Point Gabriel I'm going to thank you we
are going to come back to you later but
now we're going to go back to Kristen
salumi she's of course in front of the
court the opposite side where you've
been standing Gabriel and Kristen take
us through what we might expect happen I
mean Donald Trump is known for shall we
say going off peace a little bit going
off script there are going to be cameras
around
there will be we understand cameras
inside at least the court hallways what
do we expect from Donald Trump
well we know Donald Trump has painted
this investigation as a Witch Hunt he's
accused the district attorney Alvin
Bragg of attempting to affect the 2024
presidential election and he has not
hesitated to talk about the situation
here so anything is possible when he
arrives at the courthouse behind me it's
it's possible he might try to talk uh to
the media or to supporters who've
gathered outside but the security
presence here is so tight it's so
difficult to move around the courthouse
at this time I don't know if you can see
the police officers behind me just in
the last half hour they have really
increased
Street they've stopped allowing cars to
go through they've stopped allowing
pedestrians to go through the media
where I am we're all stuck in a pen so
exactly what happens as Gabe was saying
it's really hard to know because this is
so unprecedented and in some ways it's a
routine Court proceeding where someone
is accused of a crime you come in you
acknowledge the crime you do some
paperwork you enter a plea before the
judge and the real investigation and
trial happens much later but of course
this is unprecedented this is a former
president that is coming here to the
courthouse
to to face these charges what will
happen inside after the the fingerprints
and the paperwork happens and he heads
to that Courthouse there will be the
actual arraignment that's where he's
presented with the charges and enters a
plea we know he'll say not kill guilty
now another thing Gabe was talking about
a lot of the unknowns here another thing
that's unknown
in an arraignment the judge can read the
charges out loud but the defendant
typically has the right to waive the
reading of the charges and not have them
said out loud in the courtroom so will
we here for the first time
in the courtroom those charges we just
don't know or will it come out when the
paperwork is revealed afterwards we're
expecting to learn this today but
nothing is a hundred percent confirmed
the district attorney Alvin Bragg will
speak publicly about the case for the
first time after all of the proceedings
are done he's called the press
conference to address the media at that
time and uh assumably we will get a lot
more information at that point about the
specifics and of course we know from the
witnesses who've been called to speak in
the secret grand jury proceedings and
from leaks from from the courthouse if
this does involve the hush money payment
that the former president made through
his fixer to uh uh adult film star the
president has always denied that there
was an affair with his film star or
knowledge of the payment the payment
itself wouldn't be illegal unless it was
combined with covering up other crimes
uh and and that's the details of which
we're waiting to hear from the
courthouse from the lawyers
um up until now Trump's team has said
that even he does not know the they do
not know the exact extent of the charges
um so that's just a little bit of of the
flavor and the expectation and the hype
that we're having out here and and and
and I can tell you that all the way down
the street I don't know if there's more
security more police or more media
there's
probably hundreds of news crews out here
from
not only all around the country but all
over the world trying to get trying to
cover this story so uh clearly a lot of
interest in this case and as I was
saying earlier even
pedestrians local office workers coming
out to see what's happening and what the
latest is
all right thanks so much Kristen salumi
and Kristen and Gabriel who are with us
and they're watching this very historic
moment as the rest of us all that let me
just explain once again what we're
looking at and that we understand is the
motorcade of the former U.S president
Donald Trump making its way from his
residence in New York towards that
Manhattan Court
where for the first time in the US's
history a former U.S president will be
criminally charged this is obviously a
very historic moment and a very
polarizing moment
for the United States of America
and Amy Koch is a republican political
strategist she joins me now on Skype
from Minneapolis Amy I'm sure you're
watching these pictures as we all are
and I'm wondering how do you see this is
this a moment of Triumph for the
supremacy of law for the principle that
everyone is equal before the law no
matter how powerful you are you can be
brought to Justice or is this a case of
how politicized the law has become in
America
well lest anyone thought that American
politics was getting boring we give you
today
um and I you know I don't I don't know
that it's a Triumph and all right I'm
very sorry Amy I apologize I have to I
have to take us to Gabriel where we
understand that the motorcade is pulling
up to where you are Gabriel
[Music]
at the courthouse he's in one of these
vehicles I think he was just in that
Third vehicle there under heavy security
a historic moment the former president
of the United States Donald Trump
being escorted into the back entrance
in a motorcade
to the courthouse
the first scene of Donald Trump's
motorcade arriving
for the ex-president of the United
States
surrender to authorities
did not see him in the vehicles but
that's common because the vehicles are
have dark Windows there helicopters
overhead buzzing for security probably
media helicopters as well but we can now
report that Donald Trump has arrived at
the courthouse here in lower Manhattan
New York
and he is now in the process of
beginning his official surrender
the motorcade went down this street and
turned left
okay
and this is the scene right now behind
the courthouse where I'm at
the entire process now moves forward
we've been talking about it for several
days now of what will happen What could
happen now we are reaching the stage of
what is happening and that is Trump
going through the process
of someone that has been indicted for
criminal charges arriving at the
courthouse to turn himself in of course
this is a normal process under criminal
indictments but this is not a normal
scene because this is not a normal
situation of course historic
now the security obviously everywhere is
uh much tighter
as the police are on of course
heightened state of alert now that Trump
is here
it's really anybody's guess
how long he could be in court or
thinking probably one hour to two hours
we know his indictment or his
arraignment is about 2 15 we believe
it's about 1 25 p.m here now so it's
looking like perhaps if everything is on
schedule oh let's see you're looking at
my watch maybe about 45 minutes for him
to have fingerprints taken perhaps a mug
shot again we do not we're not sure if
he's gonna have his mug shot taken but
that would happen within the next 45
minutes and then he will be walked down
a hallway within this judicial complex
there behind me for his official
arraignment
no protesters where I'm at for the most
part it's just people walking on the
sidewalk some people don't even know
exactly what's going on some do right
okay that's how everyone Waits Gabriel I
know it's so let's see what's next and
there's a lot of waiting no doubt to be
done right now so thanks for commenting
and taking us through we did see moments
ago the former US president Donald Trump
emerged from that motorcade and enter
the court so we'll come back to you in a
little bit Gabriel when things pick up a
little bit let me go back now to Amy
Coke she's a republican political
strategist and joins us now from
Minneapolis via Skype and Amy's so sorry
that I had I just asked you a question
and then I had to take us away from your
answer so apologies for that but now we
can pick up on that point and uh let me
put the question once again to you how
you're seeing this is a Triumph and
Vindication of Justice or is this uh
politicization of Justice
so I think that I feel like most
Americans in that you have those you
know on the far left or the that see it
as a Triumph and I think you said those
on the you know far right or the Trump
supporters that see this as a travesty
um but most of us just have this like
disquieting feeling
um of how did we get here uh and to see
this kind of moment play out uh and to
see sort of the the the you know anger
um on both sides of the issue and just
wonder how did the person elected to the
highest position in our country uh wind
up in a courtroom today uh with these
kind of charges
um it's you know it's quieting it's
disturbing it's hard
[Music]
it doesn't seem to be hurting his
popularity though within Republican
circles right the polls seems to suggest
that his popularity is going up within
Republican circles I'm talking about
right I you know that's the I think
what's the strangest and most and for me
as a republican a disappointing thing um
that when these charges are brought
um or when he's indicted uh it actually
sort of because of the strong base that
he has so many leaders in the Republican
Party come forward and defend and they
do a knee-jerk you know repetition of
what the former president says about the
situation instead of As Leaders stepping
forward and in taking up the reins and
and you know treating this in a more
traditional way
um and it just seems to me that
something like this oddly strengthens
the former president
um I think that it helps him towards his
nomination I can't believe I'm saying
that
um but I also believe that Donald Trump
will never be even if he is my party's
nominee uh won't be uh the president
again he will not be re-elected
um in this country we have three
election Cycles since his 2016 election
where Republicans have lost
um and I think that will happen again if
he is our enemy on the ballot so it is
um it's just it's something that we've
just really never experienced in my
party or in this country before
so I'm curious to know because of course
you are a republican you feel like the
Donald Trump phenomenon is increasing
increasingly hijacking the Republican
Party away from its true Direction and
values because as you said we we do
still see a lot of Republican leaders
come out and defend Donald Trump and
endorse him
right and you know I talked to many of
those leaders behind the scenes and they
don't say the same thing and so I I
would just really like so what is it the
fear of the base what happens with
something like this happened
even with the base but but with but with
high with leadership with folks and
Leadership position what they will say
quietly is different than they will say
publicly
um and I you know I just think it it
really gives legitimacy to his arguments
when someone who is yes
when you speak to them behind the scenes
and you I'm sure you asked them okay why
are you telling me this differently in
private than what you say in public what
is the answer is it that well we've got
to stay on the same step as the base of
Donald Trump
that's correct he's probably got I don't
know maybe 20
of super strong supporters and that is
enough to move the needle when it comes
to the Republican vote or at least
that's how they perceive it I actually
disagree
um but that is that is the answer that's
the only one that I can come up with and
the only one that I can get anyone to
say
it's difficult to look in a crystal ball
at this point but this is going to be a
long process in terms of the the court
proceedings right
maybe a year or more away before a trial
is concluded in a ruling issued
what are your thoughts on the meantime
of
how that might impact the election race
right well I think what it does
is now stepping in and you even saw with
already declared Republican candidates
like um former Ambassador Nikki Haley
she has largely
excited with Trump on this issue and so
in the past traditionally something you
know would sort of blow up in the media
or something bad like this would happen
the opponents would step in and and use
that opportunity you're not seeing that
um and so I think as this continues and
as you said it can be it could be months
it could be a year which takes us fully
and firmly past the caucuses past the
primaries and into the general election
um it could have sort of a
quieting effect on any opposition to
Donald Trump within the Republican Party
what does it do nationally to the
election race since you've got the
crystal ball out let me keep you going
yeah no I I absolutely
loot that
goes
um that Donald Trump has been an issue
on the ballot 2016 he definitely had
coattails he definitely helped
Republicans that's because he was new
and people saw him as a businessman and
a non-traditional who spoke his mind
um but 2018 2020 and 22 22 all proved to
be disasters for the Republican party
and I would expect that will continue
for 2024. much much to my chagrin
all right and I had in the last hour a
republican member who was quite
supportive of Donald Trump and I put
some some questions to him some critical
questions so you're going to have to
bear with me now when I put the opposite
to you from the perspective of the base
when you listen to the base of Donald
Trump they have a very different
Narrative of what's happening in the
Republican party they would say that
some of those leaders they would say
yeah they're quite hypocritical they
don't represent the values that they as
believe in and they believe are American
values that they're just looking for
power why would anyone want a Republican
party that is led by such figures rather
than Donald Trump who in their
perspective at least stands for what he
really believes in
because I
they're not reflective of the values
that I grew up as a conservative which
was smaller government strong defense uh
uh you know working with our allies
across the world to bring peace all the
things that Ronald Reagan George H.W
bush George W bush
and and many more like professed I I
don't feel that I feel like the
allegiance is to Donald Trump and this
is America that's not but Amy they would
say other those figures like the
historical ones that you've referred to
whether it's Ronald Reagan and so on who
stand for a principle other than Donald
Trump or is there really the deeper
crisis within the Republican party that
other than Donald Trump it doesn't know
really what it stands for other than
seeking power for their own personal
agendas
I think that's when you have happens
when you have such a strong personality
that comes in and it has become about
Donald Trump it's become you're with him
or you're against him and for folks like
me that want to talk about the issues
that want to talk about the principles
to want to talk about what we stand for
which is frankly what Americans want to
hear we're about they just haven't had
that and so if it's you know even though
they might not agree with the left and
all the things that they're doing at
least they're not the party of Donald
Trump and that's what this is coming
down to and I just I'm very disappointed
to see that kind of boil down to
whatever he says represents the
Republican party because that's
absolutely not how I was raised as a
Republican
all right thanks so much Amy it's been
good talking to you thank you for
sharing your perspective with us
appreciate it